foreign
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple goes
you say that now
[Music]
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
death clerks around every corner
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like
is anybody else seeing this
you do we're in a fight whether we like
it or not or else we're stuck here for
eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism or a
big trouble
this house
Souls but there's always room
for one more
my friend was mugged he was tall he had
hair that was sticking out of a what a
top hat Top Hat yes yes Top Hat you
would pull a rabbit out of it probably
uh eyes they were a bit uh something
nice like a raccoon when they sit back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
foreign